You
Hello sipping some apple juice
The wishes I
Was trying to find the stair emoji so I could stare at you all and you guys are doing terrible jokes
But it wasn't working out so you're lucky. I couldn't find the stair emoji to stare at you and your terrible jokes
Maybe start me to study. I want my phone. I want my oh there you go. I'm alive. Hello
Good job. No, not that stare. No, I
Met
Hold on. I'm gonna try to find it. I meant this stair
Wish I could make the chat. Where is it? It's literally just like there we go
I just wanted to do that
That's my live reaction to your jokes and chat
She be one one I know
Emotional damage, um, yeah, we're gonna play holo cure. I've never played holo cure before
it's so cute and
I know it's a it's a really cute free-to-play game. I've never seen any gameplay. I've never seen anybody play this I
Mean like I haven't watched them. I'm not saying people don't play the game cuz I know they do
Um
So it'll be it'll be cute
Mume is broken. Is she I see her I have to do I have to unlock characters because I see I'm missing some people
Just a few just a few people just a smattering
But I like wedding which so you guys are just like you should play this is my am I lagging?
Where am I? I
Feel like I I'm extra my physics or extra-physicking right now for some reason
Yes, you unlocks of the gotcha where you can't spend real-life money what you have to gotcha for characters. Okay, I
Don't know what the question mark is. Let me have a shop
Is it is a crony just hanging out um cool. Oh
Wait, where's that a Chan? I'm stupid
I don't know what's happening. Um
I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. She looks like crony for a split second. I
corrected myself
Hello
I'm moon gravity in my own donkano
I
I'm sorry
Guys, and I'm not gonna know everybody. I'm not I'm gonna tell you right now. I'm not gonna know everyone
Because I don't watch a lot of the Japanese holo because I don't really watch people that I don't know the language
I
Don't watch a lot of holo. I watch like maybe like a couple of them and
That's okay. You can revoke my card. I'm sorry
It's all right, but I understand
So I can play as a meal it's merely have a freaking gun
Girl
Mid-range stab attack. Okay, maybe she'll be like Hades the pixels are pixel art so cute
Tentacle shoots out front. I do I love Ina. You know design is awesome Kiara
She has a little sword. Oh my god, it's like a Phoenix feather. I love it
Little chicken feather and then you got Mori
I'm I'm wondering so let me see 90
She's lost speed
She's HP
Amelia's the most balance
You know has no crit hits, which are you we think she would have a little bit of a higher crit hit
Although Mori has a
Pretty good crit hit as well. She's hella. She's also as balanced as Gura. I might go a Mori
Yeah, I think Mori is actually the most balance
We'll do Mori defeat the last botch but I need a
Forgot to you guys can't hear anything
And neither can I cuz my headphones in
You called it
Reaper rapper. Yeah, I saw you guys
guessing, but I'm like, I don't know. We'll see
I'm like, what did you bet?
Take sound should be fine
Oh
Okay
Left stick to toggle or right stick to aim. Oh I can aim. Okay. Oh
Oh, I like how they're oh, I like how they're um
Like cover things. Oh, this is pretty cool for each target to feed increase attack by two
This is yeah, like whatting witch or vampire survivor
Increase damage by 20% fire a fast piercing tail target a random target. Oh
Give me that I'll do the first one
Nice I can just walk around them the too bad the fans have ended up like this
Hamburger as hell if I presume who is this little guy? It's skelly
Get him. Oh, he's he's a little bit. Oh, man. Oh
Okay, I'm kind of getting ah
All the skeletons help I'm so sorry Mori. I didn't think we'd all get circled
Oh
What's the gold
Targets within a hundred pixels take 10% extra damage he started to feed increase attack by 3% for certain
Oh, I could literally just do that up. Okay, but orbiting boy. Oh books
That's so funny
Gain a shield that absorbs up to 15 damage every 56 shield refreshes. Okay
I'll just I'll just do that. Oh god
It's nice that I can aim
Although I think someone did mention to me in wedding which I don't have to I can't I don't have to auto aim
You get that something that could be turned off. I like this one because it's a sweeping arc
I feel like I kill more
And it's I wonder if I can get the speed up for it. What is this? Oh
My god, can I run what is this? Okay, the hell that scared me I
Don't want to get ganged up on again quick look for a way out. Oh, what's that? What's the box? Oh
Oh coins, okay
Throw a glow stick. Oh
Okay, I'm
Gosh, I'll do the uber sheep
Because I feel like that's how it's right. Oh, we'll find out. Ah
Kill him. Oh, there we go
Oh my god, I can't even get to the burger
That guy's big
Burger
The music's really good
What's the anvil
Hold on. What's the anvil?
Increase my movement speed let's do it
Please I just want to get to the anvil I
Can upgrade
Upgrade I might die
What's over there, ah
It's actually good I did the food thing
Was I saying there's a 20% chance to expose them for the what? Oh
I should get more skills
Oh, I'm toggling what am I okay? Well, I don't know I
Thought I'm aiming when I click but I guess not
Let's do repels. Oh, see yeah, we'll do we'll do a little bit of that. What's that? Ah, I
Don't know what this is. I want it
Can I what's this thing what's the book oh?
The book the box I have to step on it
Oh, I got another book nifty
Let's do headphones
Terrifying I'm so scared. Oh my god. This is scary all the Takenashi's
Hell
See the food things are good. It was a good call. Oh my eyes itchy
Is this yeah goo?
It's fine. I'm fine. I'm fine
I
Can I have a drink sake gain 50 max maybe for six points until I'm actually what I don't know the means
Okay, I don't I don't know math
I
Okay brings down their defenses. Yeah miss
I'm stuck why oh, I'm stuck on a freaking pillar. Oh my god. We got it. We got to get out of here
I
So locked in give me this food, please all this fuck foods up there
Yippie the chickens are so fast
I
Let me try look a chat math optional. Yeah, I just think what sounds the coolest
There's a little rabbit hole stuff to discover in the game. You know a lot of fun
Okay, yeah, see it like I know they're about someone said they're about to do like an update or something. Oh
The mascots are so cute yet so terrifying. Oh
My god, why do I keep getting attacked?
Oh my god
I
Need another upgrade when we go down here. Maybe I'll grab some stuff
I'm close to the next level, but not quite. Can I like I wish I could sprint
Ha ha dodge dodge food dodge food dodge almost run into to get hit it's fine
Ah, give me the sandwich. It's fine. Oh
My god, do they get faster what's happening here?
Okay, I feel like they got stronger
Multiply all damage dealt by 1.3 times increase haste. Oh, that's it hate
Take 30% more damage. I don't want to do that
I
Think I'll do this one
Why are you guys right behind me? Oh my god, they're literally just following me in a little single file line
It's gonna walk around see what I can find
I
Fones been doing work for first time playing. Yeah, using a controller. No, I'm using can you not hear the tap tap of my keys?
Using keyboard
Should I be using controller for this? Oh
Look at the little crocodile
That's okay, what do I need to move my mouse for do I need to like do something?
Do I have like an attack
So you can hit behind me, okay when I back up that's true
I should be using that but I'm not I just wasn't really touching my mouse. I'll be honest with you. Oh
My god, please go this way
This is okay. I'm just gonna go through them. I'm missing the sandwiches
Drop a sandwich
Do it
Don't drop it behind me. Oh, I got it
I'm so scared
It's gonna casually just backtrack
In a sandwich sandwich sandwich is so helpful. Oh my god
I
Wonder if there's like an absorption rate I can get up. Oh
That's okay, she's not happy. Oh, I don't really need the sandwich
I
Feel like they just got faster
Sorry, I should be aiming behind me while I'm moving away
But I'm not because I'm so scared. I just it's like I'm playing a horror game
This is more terrifying than wedding which
This one has a bat. What is he have a bat?
Why do you have a bat, bro
Now
I squeeze through squeeze squeeze
Oh, I might not make it bros the onslaught of the dead beat
That's a player killer wave. Yeah, definitely
I'll see character select. Oh costume hit. Okay
How do I get how do I roll gotcha? Let's be on me
Cuz it's funny
I'm soldier. So wait, what happens if I break the yagusa to you? Oh
Yeah, I'm pew pew in I'm pew pew in
Solid first attempt. Yeah, it's normal to use a lot. Here is the easiest. I
Don't need the easiest you kidding me
Plot wait, I just really says it plug type. I don't know if I like that
Okay
I might level up the shot next
Okay, what's your 20% more damage to the shields, let's do the body pillow shields. Oh
What happened what did I get
I'll play the hardest character
Get pew pew'd I need to start shooting
Okay, I'm just gonna walk through them
Oh
No, oh no, it's happening. I'm getting ganked up on
This one's harder to like grab health. I think yeah, mario was a little bit easier because I think she's easier with cloud crowd control
I
Where's the flower I'm kidding. This isn't wedding much
Yeah, focus in front of me and actually grab
Come on give me a level. Okay slow damage
I
Want a doggy get them look at this freaking dog. Oh
My god, this dog is going absolutely ham
Oh, yeah, let's do that
This dog is wrecking
Nurse horns are broken too
Oh my god, I need to go where the dog is because like what the hell is freaking wrecking everyone
I
Need a psycho
Don't I literally all I need is bubba
He just barks and just kills everyone get him. Yeah, buddy
Oh
My god, he's perfect. I can just now it's he makes it easier for me to get stuff get him get him get him bubba
Get him
Come on
Nightly milk, let's do it
Oh
All right, let's do level up the pistol shot been waiting for that
Oh, let's go. Let's go
I wish that how I moved it like my mouse it would like
Um, oh
It would like kind of I don't know how like
Stagger, I don't know how to
I don't know how to
Say what's the word
I
Just a gun
What's this oh, I thought it was a potato on the ground
Oh opening now I sold got messed up
Okay, I need to loop back around so I can get all these oh never mind. I am not looking looping back around
Can bubba like fetch that for me I think they can I think they can fetch some of these
Um
Bullets ricochet. Oh my god
Oh boy, what?
I don't know what's happening
Oh, what the heck is this?
What is the golden yaku?
I'm gonna die because I'm just so confused
What is this
What
I'm so thrown off I can't get to the golden yaku
Let's slow let's slow everybody down
I don't even know I'm not even like aiming anymore
I
Get them puppy sick. Um, I just need to walk around and get more stuff. I missed
Uh, yeah
I think I might buff the puppy next. Oh, did I accidentally click off? Okay, I did
Let's go over here
All right, we'll just pick up what we lost
I can't buff the puppy
All right, I'll get some headphones then
This is so fun. What the hell
Oh
All right, we'll loop back around to the puppy
I also didn't see the arrow. Let's do that. Let's do this delivery
Okay chat, this is epic. I wonder what happens
If he's calling me agoo is what what's his name? I just call me agoo
Yago
Hey, I speak English. Okay
I don't know Japanese
My Japanese pronunciation is terrible
Buff the puppy
Get um, oh what the hell give me that
Uh
What can I upgrade I can't upgrade the puppy
Let's do the nightly milk
Someone calling me shut up. I'm playing hollow cure go go go break it break it break it
I'm just gonna go. Why aren't you dead yet?
The dog is broken
Well, like broken as in like good you guys know what I mean. You guys are gamers. You guys know what I mean
Keep it up puppy
Oh
Yeah, you get him
This is actually it's pretty the nurses horns thing is pretty
Cracked because when you I have a multiple hit thing like this
I have more chances to gain that health back, which is pretty sick
Oh, I forgot there's arrows. I'm not paying attention to arrows. Let me go to the arrow
I'm so focused
To the arrow
You
The horn you see would be more broken. Oh my god help. It's okay
Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Am I dying? Am I dying? Am I dying? Am I dying? Am I dying? Am I dying? I'm
Uh, let me do the shield
I survived I survived the onslaught. Uh, I don't have the arrow anymore. It's that way
You need to steal some health
What the hell
Oh my god, okay, okay, okay, let's do
Let's get this anvil get the gun
My health is already back. See that's a oh frick. Um
Bro, I am
Dying
Well, I'm not dying. I mean, I'm like, I'm awesome. Wait until she learns about collabs
What
What do you mean wait until she learns about collabs? Can I like collab with other youtubers?
I can't upgrade that anymore. All right, negate one hit
Where did my dog go? Oh, there he is
I
Awakened I don't know what awakened means
Let's do let's do the glow stick
I forgot this glow stick is just
Ah
It's loop back around. Oh my god help help
I'm terrified. Please don't point that upwards
Um
Um, it's okay. It's okay. We're good. We're fine. We're good. We're good
Towards the arrow. Oh, I can't I have to like go past him
Okay, I made it
It looks like cheese
Trying to get to whatever's over here
Oh, oh great. I'm right in the line of fire. Wow
He is coming
I may die after this. I don't know how much damage that does
Do I have to fight him do I have to beat him or do I just have to run away? Oh
I did it
I have done it easy clap
Oh gee
I don't know what to upgrade
Headphones are broken
Hidden dog stat is there hidden dog stat
Guys help guys help how am I still alive? I just
Oh my god. Oh my god
Let's get the lava. Oh, oh sweet the puppy gave me a way in inville
Uh
Oh
They drop a lot
Yeah
Yippie
Best focus on more damage facts
Oh my god, uh, I'll just do this one for them
Oh
There's a lot happening
Help what are you what the hell?
Clock face. I don't remember. I don't know what any of their things are called
I could never remember
Oh, no
Oh
There's so much happening on my screen
A little dog is putting in work. That's all I'm gonna say
Oh up an attack speed. Yeah, give me the attack speed
What what's happening? Oh my god. Oh
Lord
I I can't even see where I am
I
I don't know. I'm still here. What is that?
What's happening
I know. Oh, yeah crony stuff clock face
Oh
My god, I'm just literally clicking anything at this point
Kill them kill them kill them get him. I might buff the books next
I
Got him I got his ass
Let's do
What
Oh, sweet, I was gonna level that. Oh my god
Ah
I could throw two lava buckets
Dang it
I would probably be dead if it wasn't for the nurses ones
Who wants to tango
Are they mice are the are the cronies mice
Because I think of like hickory dickory dock the mouse went up the clock or are they just like clock people? I don't
What what what are they wearing?
What's up with the
I know they're clocks, but it looks like it has mouse ears
The mice I know those are Bay's stuff. I'm talking about the
Okay, I'm gonna go over to one eventually
And you guys will see
Okay, so you're so not frick
Ow, I can't even focus on them. It doesn't
Do you see
Well, there's none around so let me just walk through here and pick up stuff
Oh
Looks like they're holding books, but they're holding axes. Oh my god. He's huge
Yeah
Death death for ye. Oh
This is this is definitely an addicting game I can tell why people want to play this a bunch
What are the little what does that thing mean up there little sparkle points?
Are those people that I've killed?
Are those the fans that I've murdered?
It's pretty neat
Yes
Ah
There's saplings in why do they also look like that there's two variants of saplings for some reason
Oh the Owlet's I don't know what people again. I don't know the names
Kill them with kindness
Oh gosh, oh see see they look like the little clock ears on their head
I might die
I'm just gonna walk through it they look like little mouse ears
Oh
Two anvils don't mind if I do
I'll get another book
Now I got four books
Oh my god, what's happening?
Let's get more glow sticks. Holy crap. I'm I'm dying. I don't know what's happening
Look at all of them
Oh no, I'm stuck
Gaming
I know it's like the bell thing, but they it looks like little mouse ears
So I thought that would have been I thought that was like a cool little thingy
Am I doing good I don't know if I'm doing good or not
I
I'm doing great, okay
Oh my god
Is he a gun? Oh, no, it just looks like it
What happened to him?
I
Was he not done yet
I'm losing books
He's dead I have defeated him
Oh
My god, puppy bread who has puppy bread
These puppy breads are huge
A puppy bread
I call it a brupi bread puppy
Oh sauna rip that's right. I forgot she had the puppy bread
Um
I don't which should I upgrade
Let's do it. I want even more anples
Order these giant ones. Oh
Oh, I just absorb everything in the vicinity. Holy crap
Oh, yeah, see don't they look like mouse ears? Why are they getting bigger?
I don't know if I'm gonna make this bros. Where's my dog? He's over there. He doesn't even know what he's doing either
We'll just go towards the
Stuff
Oh, I almost missed the anvil. I didn't see it past all the chaos
They look like mouse ears their default size for 11 minutes. Is that true?
Get away for my box. I'm stuck on a tree
Oh
Why did I get three things do I get to pick or is it all of them?
Oh, okay
Oh, baby a triple I'm scared
10 seconds left
Oh my god
Oh my god, I'm not small on me. What the hell?
Uh, that's that's actually terrifying and only how she's running at me like that
What who are these guys they look so funny looking
These are these are always that's so funny to me
Already where'd she go? Oh, there she is. I can't really shoot her
These hollow live bombs look like shopping bags. I'm stuck. Oh god. I'm stuck. I'm stuck help
You
Let's get some glow stick up in here
Oh my god lava buckets, I don't know
Get some food. Oh my Jesus Christ
Oh
My god small army, please
Trying to like get her with the burn damage
There's so many of them
Increase my hp increase it increase that shiz. Oh
Oh run flea
Give me that give me that give me that
If there's an arrow I have not been looking at it
I
May is still chasing me
There I was at the top of the screen. Oh, I see it. I know I see it
You kill I may you win I have to take her out. All right, but
I
React to my oh, I
I did it
Oh
What's hollow house, okay, but how do I gotcha for people?
Bubba
Shop
Oh, okay
They view
Okay, what
I got crony
I
Okay
Actually, I kind of if mume's cracked I kind of want mume
What tears I don't
Know
It can't help
Agent
The pity system
Who is good
Who do I like
Who is like a rare oh, I got crony again
Oh
Mume get
It's destiny
I asked and I received is there another place where I can spend the coins
Oh by upgrades
What
Which one should I do well, I can only afford like a few of them get special attack
I I
Let's see armory. Oh is this stuff that I found that's cool rain have just hopped on my lap
Look at the sea look at that. Oh look at that. Oh my god, reina you're pulling my headphones
What what is that meow what
What reina buff
Reina are your meows buffing who's reina's oh she
She
I don't know reina who's your oh she can you tell us
Reina tell us your oh she
Oh
Reina who's your oh she
She's shy she doesn't want to talk about it
Oh, she's
Oh, that's true. Maybe I'm no she
You know boomi wouldn't oh she me fia would oh she me and reina would oh she me boomi would not
Be alert group gonna look like that soon
Boomi is the oh she
I should get if I get um
A mascot like not a mascot like a little like cat holding thing
It'll probably be a boomi because boomi's the most like on here
But then I'll get stuff of like fia and reina afterwards
Boomi would or oh she coronae cuz she boxes
Oh reina you just drooled on my leg. I was like, why do I feel wetness on my leg? She just drooled on me
Oh my god, that's so much
Are you a dog? Why did you drool on me?
What was that you're just so happy teacher she started drooling she's purring so hard she started drooling
Now my she like drooled on my leg and on my pillow that i'm sitting on
And on my leg is so wet and I'm trying to wipe it in my blankets with she just drooled like a bunch
What the heck
Boomi will drool when he like it's funny. They like make biscuits and they're start drooling and oh my god. What are you doing?
Look at the achievements
You
Okay destroy yaku statue
Lose after 10 minutes in a game I could do that
Do I get these I can pet baba I can get defeated by yaku
Fail a one plus two plus two hands thing
A velar cafe and the patreons can interact with all the girls pets where they have coffee that would be so cute
I wish I had game mate building ability because I would totally build a game for velar
Our game is on the way
Almost done. They're finishing it up
We're just waiting on them because we just passed off. We didn't just pass off but they're finishing up adding our audio to everything
I know and it was a big endeavor and a big investment for scrawny and it's gonna be free
So you guys should well you better freaking play it
I keep forgetting about the game
Um, so so it does die for a little bit and I was like wait
scrawny how's the game going
Just like oh it's no fun
Is the game good? I don't know. I haven't played it
There's no there's no micro transactions. Oh, it's it's zero out of 10 because no micro transactions
Will it be like it sure it's free you can give money if you want I don't know
What's the genre not telling
Not telling
Probably something you've played before probably something similar
It is based off of a very popular game
The genre is smug sheebie
Raina, please don't try to take my apple juice
She's rubbing against the microphone
I don't know. Oh, you're so snuggly Raina. Oh, you really head butt in the mic, huh?
The
Genre is video game
It's a double me cry game of dealer gals
I'm not gonna tell you what it is, but it's a game. It's it's based off of a very popular game
It's a game. You've probably played before you're going to enjoy it. It's very nice very well made
Either some spicy stuff in it
You're gonna like it
It better be a smash cool. That would be pretty awesome. Actually, it's not but that would be sick
It's dnd. We just made we just made balder's gate made a whole balder's gate except it's us
We in we made mods of our own selves and we put them in balder's gate
So you can romance us in balder's gate. No kidding. Is it who need pop?
No
I'm not gonna tell you I'm not gonna tell you
Smashing
All right
I
Throw an onigiri in an arc
Okay, how do I use my super how do I use my alt?
Feeler smash
I actually forget what the game is called. I know I have that
Oh, what is it?
Oh, I just remembered it
It's actually it's funny because it's a play on words because you know how you know how strong he is
Um, I'm gonna play uh, I kind of a play not as mume yet. I want to play
I think it's natural I play as
Gura
If she wasn't you don't think she knows something else I click when bar is full
Okay
It's pretty good mid-range attack. It's pretty like it almost gets me to the end of the screen
What bar the bar that's I thought that's my level though
Okay, the song is kind of making me go a little crazy
Only the littlest bit
Short height grants if you just dodge an attack
Oh
What
I don't really understand this one gain 15 max hp for every six points of total max hp
Okay, so I get more hp. Let me do that then
Oh, okay, I don't know what I pressed
Why am I on fire? I'm on fire. I don't know how to do Gura's voice
No, I don't know how to do Gura's voice. I'm not going to try I feel I have I haven't listened to her
Gura streaming a little bit
Oh
Yeah, I know I pressed right click can I do it again? I can't
Give me a hundred hp
I just have to walk through them
Oh, I see now I see the bar
Okay, let's do let's do it. We're gonna get up close. Oh, I was aiming the other way
Nifty super sane
Shork
I don't know what this means. I'm picking it because it sounds cool
I don't know what my cats are doing
I
This would be great for me to do this shark thing for some crowd control right now. Let me see if I can just skirt the edge
I'll do the food. I can't do it yet. Oh, no, I can
Yes
Power Atlantis
That was pretty neat
Press play
Sorry I wanted some crowd control stuff
The whirlpool is pretty nice
I try to play a little bit differently what?
I
Wait, what a bar. Oh, oh interesting
P kale
I
Had phones are beloved I'm just rounding them up
Trying to use different things so I can besides just like spamming the same stuff
Oh, let's do
Ah
There's so much of these on the ground. I wish I could pick more up. It's so weird that a plug tail comes out
Okay, I don't see any arrows on my screen sometimes the little shot that comes from her throws me off and I think it's an arrow
Oh
No, we got to get through you made it
If only add bubble with me
I forget I can use my super
Do that in a bit. I need to think I need to loop around them and do it
All right, let's let's do it this trees in the way
Nice I think I don't really know
Oh my god
I also need to I wanted to get the credit card so I can get more drops
What's a star what's a star do valley no, I'm sorry it sounds terrible
Oh
Something just bit me. Ow. Ow. Ow. Ow. I feel like it's got fit by something on my neck
It's the spider I saved yesterday
I got the chapel
I'm not paying attention
Look at all this delicious food. Ah, they're stuck on a tree
Can I please get the credit card
See who play of course the box is where I need to go
I might just run into that
Oh
Hello, hi
Pretty sure your marine asks for live applications. Oh, yes, I remember I have seen that clip
Oh, okay, we'll get to that we'll do we'll do the headphones at some point. Oh see perfect
Who's mascot is the little dragon?
Oh, it's an alligator
Splash of unknown. Oh, give me that. Give me the nurses horns, baby
We'll get everything we'll get all this stuff
This game is so fun. I could leave play this right
I never realized how much I like games like these and wedding which definitely showed me that
You should probably play vampire survivor at some point
The orange thing no the aren't the alligators. Yeah, those are the teammates. I meant the orange ones
I meant the little orange dudes
Not the not the crocodiles
Shrimps, okay, I couldn't tell if they were shrimps. They look like dragons
I never knew what the chumbuds looked like
Oh my god, big dude, where'd my thing go? Oh, there's
Oh, there's an arrow. I gotta not pay attention. Wow, look at all this food
Let's do power of Atlantis. It's the red one do
Headphones
It looks like dragons
Okay, this is the player killer wave this might get me because I don't have
The full nurses horns. Nope. Nope. I seem to be doing fine
Oh
My god, silver you goof
Should I should I be attempting to kill you?
Oh, oh
That crowd just fucking you went to me
Get you go get him. He's turning green
Oh, what is that?
How convenient, okay, uh, let's do that. Oh, did I grab credit card yet? I don't think I did upgrade the nurse horn
I
Loop around and do a little whoa, bam
Ow, I feel like the L just sped up and I just oh god
Not the laser
Ow
I miss ahead
Oh
This man is already to take the chateau
I
Think I did it when the thing was nearby I couldn't really tell
Sometimes when I'm not looking at the little little white and black dudes
I they look like question marks and I'm not looking at their faces
Ah
I like how these have pompadours little rat guys. I thought that was neat
Oh my god
You're still alive
See an arrow I'm going for it
God it's fine. Oh my god. They like latch on to you. Holy crap
I need to get my damage up
Oh
This is nice
I am indeed
I am doing just fine
That magnet did pale
Okay
Oh
The dodge is pretty good
I need to loop around everybody
Ah
Die
Ouch
Oh
Yeah, the nurses horn is extremely helpful for like just even surviving the game in general
Bob and weave
Yeah, that's true. Oh, not the tree
Okay, there's more stuff. Oh, what is okay, hold on seeing some green
And we'll go back up for the other stuff. Oh my god, I keep getting stuck on things
What is this
I
Decrease damage of the main weapon but increased damage of all the other weapons. I don't want that
They don't really have a lot of weapons. I only have the
Uh
I can upgrade my stance with that stamp while I've already walked away
Okay
What are the shrimp wearing
Haha
Taxis it's looks like a ball of yarn
Oh
What the hell is going on
I
Sorry, I am
Oh, I didn't know the boss was still alive. Boomi. I can't see past your bomb
I
Gough the achievement
Uh
Can't upgrade the headphones anymore and get the max hp
Let's do that because I haven't upgraded that yet
So
What is so what does this do exactly
That just doesn't sound good
I wish I could get rid of it so I don't have to see it on my screen distracting me
Destroy the yaku statue
Yeah
Oh my god, I'm stuck on the tree
Can you sell or use it I can choose to sell it. How do I sell it?
Oh the boss is still alive
So
How do I sell it
Oh, I just click on it
I figured it out
I wish I could get the credit card, but it's just like not spawning that anymore
Arrow gone
But I wanted to sell it
That's what I wanted to do. I wanted to sell the stamp
I wonder why they chose stamps
I
Saplings getting caught in this looks really funny
Nope
I guess I'm just chilling running around
Oh, there's stuff dropping up there. I'm like, what's what do I do now? I'm waiting for stuff to drop and it's all right here
Hand stamps from cons maybe must be like sticks again, they're just cute
Damn this plug is doing work. Oh, I'm gonna die. I didn't even freaking notice
Damn it, I'm kind of pissed
Because I could have definitely beaten it
I didn't realize how many people were on me. I didn't look. Why was my health so when did my health gets that low?
When did my health get that low?
Okay, let's try one more can I choose a different stage
Oh
What
What I can fish this is this a fishing minigame
Wait, what is everybody doing? I'm kind of scared. It's like they're actually like coming in and it's freaking me out
Wait, what?
This is a game within the game
Oh, what
This is overwhelming I
I didn't know
Oh
Am I suddenly
Check behind the house, I want to buy some expedited soil
I'll buy some tomato seeds and I can grow tomatoes like my mom
Why did mori leave that guys it's freaking me out. It's like they're actually here
Fancy
Do I have to water it?
I should have picked four
Oh
I already watered the plants
What the heck
P. R. Oh my god, it's like I'm eating them. Hi
Are you going
Okay
Okay, I can cook
Oh my god guys, I'm freaking out. There's a lot more in this game than I thought try fishing. Okay
Wait
How am I supposed to how am I supposed to do this?
Do I have to type do I have to tap the things?
What I don't know what buttons I'm supposed to be pressing
Uh because it's I'm assuming maybe it's w instead of the up button
Oh, see okay, I figured out it was the w button. Hi crony
Hi
Look at Ina moving with her tentacles. They're very cute. She said go behind the house
What the
What are they doing? They're looking at Ina's back. What are they doing?
Tomatoes fully grown oh
Okay
Why is this the one I watered it first? Okay, and it was the last one to do
Sick wait, what else do I need to do? Oh, I forgot to I had to grab the shrimp. Oh, I stole fish from am I?
Okay
How do I cook it I need wheat I need to grow some wheat
Hello I would like to purchase your best wheat
This time I'll do
You
I wish there was a faster way to do this okay, I gotta water them
Especially with the I don't like having to quit everything
Did I did I glitch it because I quit too fast I think I did oh wait no, it's watered because it's raining
I can press e instead okay, so I can go inside the house
Oh, and then I can make stuff okay
I'm gonna steal their shrimp
Oh, and I got it and they caught a fish too. All right
Nifty
What are they doing?
Sorry pal this road's closed for now you saw the casino still this game is so elaborate I can gamble
I can gamble in this game
I
Does she be ever look up what
Brother excuse me
Um just done I harvest this
They're still developing the casino I see I see
I just want to make
I just want to make tempura
I'm gonna steal her shrimp get me a shrimp
Do you look at do you guys ever look up rule 34 every song
Oh
Hurry up the expedited it is probably the way to go okay, let's buy some stuff. Um
I can get a simple couch I can get a bed we'll get all the basics
But that's too everything's so expensive Jesus
I I barely have enough money for a clock
All right, I already have that I was buy it anyways can I get a different wall I can get a wooden wall fabulous
For anymore, okay
Do I how do I play stuff build mode?
Oh
Well perfect how many can I put
I
Need to make six
Four five six for all of the alert girlies because that's where they stay
um
When they come over to hollow live
Boobie and rain are playing and then I'll put some couches. Why is the couch bigger than the bed?
Can I flip this can I can I rotate it?
No
How do I get
How do I get rid of this?
Yeah, and then you can just roll over each like and then to get out of bed
And we got in all the dining table
That's where we all eat at
Yep, that looks pretty nice
Fabulous
Can I get in the bed?
Oh, I can't get in like pokemon style. Can I at least sit down? No, can I at least eat? No
I
My wheat has fully grown girl collect my wheat for me
Okay, I get way more wheat than I do tomatoes
Oh, that one only gave me one though. Oh fish look at all these fish cheese
Oh, I don't even need to fish
We'll do it for me. Okay. I got tempura tuna sandwich. Oh
Cook
I'm cooking a chumbud right now
Let's cook I'm cooking in the rain. Let's cook a tuna sandwich. Why is there tomatoes in a tuna sandwich?
I
Don't have any rice. How do I get rice? I have to plant rice. Don't I?
I ought to cook
I don't know what that means
Oh
Okay
Stealing your scram, can I sell?
What do I sell it for?
Sell
Is this what did I get? What is this dust exchange?
Oh
It only goes to 19 I can get 19 coins
He gives me sand and I can exchange it for coins
Oh
Can I like type in how much?
Okay, I see now I see now I see
Understandable now I get it now. I know how the math is math thing
It's over here
I'm assuming this will be a future update as well
Look how she got it, but oh
Sorry, I didn't mean to take the bat. Why is this one just passed out? Oh, no
Sorry, I didn't mean to take out the bat and scare you all. What's this?
I can manage
Okay
I can set out
To get recruits homin takodachi
Wait are these real people
What is that
Those are names of fans
These constructions are not wish to improve how do they get names of fans is that people from
Are people that play the game?
In the hall of fame in the game
Oh
That's cool
Imagine she be
Well, I don't really I don't what do the recruits do? What do the workers do?
They make money for me
Well, I'll hire like what's efficiency
I'll hire hire Alejandro
His name is Alejandro, you know, I like that name though. I like the name for a chicken name Alejandro
Uh, no, you don't have to do that, but thank you. You don't have to post a link. I was just curious
Oh
Okay, so they just like run around in this little fields like a chow. Okay, understandable
I'll grab this screw out in this clown face
All right. Oh my god, boomie. What are you doing? What do you do? Are you chasing arena?
Oh my god, he's galloping around the house
He was chasing arena. Hi, are you okay?
I already looked behind the house guys
When they get tired you feed them when you feed and then you feed them you level up or anymore
Like a lot of money once they're upgraded
Did you hear him did you hear
Did you hear
The sound of like a toilet people he is a little elephant
He just runs around the house doing elephant noises
I call my little trumpet or my little dove because he used to coup me. He was younger. I sounded more of a dove coup
I mean
He is growling at boomy
Oh
I'm so angry she sounds because boomy came close
Oh, it's okay. Rina. He's not gonna bother you
He's not gonna bother you
Yeah, hold on. You know that's something on your head. I got it. You know like piece of dry skin
I thought that was a stomach growl
Yeah, I know that was that was rena being irritated
That's funny and then she looks at me and she looks so innocent but then when she looks at boomy she looks demonic
She's like in her face expression changes
Hi, do you see him? Why are you wagging your tail so hard? Oh, it's because he's on the counter. You can see him from here
Boomy you're laying in the water dish
Boomy your pouch is in the water dish
You're kneeling over the water dish and your pouch is in it
Sir, you're getting your pouch wet
Sir, I
I don't know what to do for you your pouch is
All right, well
He's trying to pouch juice
He's he's doing like the soy sauce thing with his pouch
Boomy
Please don't run off and knock the water over because you've done that before
Rina's completely plopped in front of my keyboard
Boomy swimming boomy doesn't like water
He thinks he's sushi
Fiya, how are you doing? Fiya's knocked out. She's on the couch sleeping. He thinks he's sushi
Rina don't chew on my headphones
Pouch the primordial pouch the cat pouch
A little little extra belly fat that they have for whatever reason
usually for
If they ran out of food, they had this primordial pouch to keep their fat storage in
They can burn that instead
Although boomy burns a lot of energy. So I don't know. Oh, he's drinking the water that he was sitting in
I guess he wanted some pouch flavored tea
The forbidden pouch
indeed
All right, I'm gonna end it here. This was really fun. The hollow hollow cure
Is it the punch, punch, pouch, punch, punch, pouch, punch
And it was very it was more enjoyable than I thought it was there's so much more in the game than I thought there was
So it's really cool
I like it a lot
I'm kind of mad I didn't win with Gura because I know I could have if I was paying attention
Are you playing again at some point? Yeah
Of course
Um, I might take a nap and then come back and play more Elden Ring. I'm not sure yet. Maybe maybe not
I don't know. Maybe I shouldn't actually know. I probably shouldn't
Um, I should probably I still haven't written the scripts for October. So I should probably do that
Um, so I'll probably work on that and then they have to
Yeah
Indeed
The wrinkles
Yeah, I still haven't written the scripts for October yet. So I might have to do that
Or you do it out we could have some Elden Ring script writing or we could use script writing stream
I should have put a script writing stream on the thing
Maybe
Yeah, I'll script write
I don't
I'm on that first because I'm still tired and I only slept for like
a millisecond because I really I forget that I can't fall asleep in like a
um five minutes
I didn't really sleep. I was kind of just there laying on my couch
Sometime next week. Yeah, maybe yeah, maybe next week. I'll uh do uh, I'll add that to the schedule
I'm meant to do it this week, but I totally forgot when I was making the schedule with you guys
I
Laughing because somebody commented under my uh, my fart short. Did you get pink eye from farting? You don't get pink eye
Did you get pink eye
That's funny and it fart on my own face. Hello
Imagine if you could that's terrifying
What did I ask you? Okay, let me find some of the ring
Let me find someone for fun
Or I can just like wait like five minutes and wait for Emmy. I might do that
Oh, no, she's a member's ASMR never mind
Let's me find someone else
Let's read Rocky because she's cute
Rocky such a cute girl said Rocky, but you guys know I'm Iraqi
She's playing Minecraft. Hold on. When does she start?
She started at four. Okay, she might be ending
Somebody go somebody go somebody go look go peek for me if she seems like she's stopping anytime soon
Sometimes go out I'm sending out a scout go forth
I'm not being shy. I'm just making sure I don't raid and they're ending
It's funny. There's just there's a there's a factor ad under my video saying sponsored
Then check yourself. No
Okay, you know, I'm just gonna seems good. Thank you. Thank you gentlemen. Thank you very much
Only been an hour it's been she started at 409 it's been almost two hours for her just like it has been for me
All right
Well, I'm shy around everybody so in Rocky seems like a really cool girl and so I'm gonna raid her
I really love uh her model and her energy. She's very adorable and sweet so
Off to Rocky you go
Go forth
I'm on the nap and then problem. No, I gotta work
I can't stream all the time. You should be you can't do it. You gotta work you got work to do
And uh, it's because I just love hanging out with you guys. I love you guys and I don't want to I don't want to leave
But I shouldn't out and I should go where
Elden right well, we'll see I'll I'll try to be productive. Maybe I'll finish like one or two scripts and then we'll see we're at
You know, you know what I'm well, you know what I'm doing. You know what I'm saying
You know what I'm you you smelling what I'm farting, you know
Okay, well you got see you in two hours. I napped for two hours
So you'd probably be like see you in five hours and I wake up. It's like 12 a.m. And I'm like it's time to stream
If I leave if I close this window is it gonna just like delete everything can I like rain is sitting on everything so I can't move
Okay, bye
Bye
Uh, bye
Out of the night and I don't see you later alligator